hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse today we're gonna
continue on with what we did yesterday
which was editing WordPress plugins to
try to get data from our custom fields
to show up in the data we get from the
WP graph QL plugin so since yesterday I
was able to get some of the data but not
the data from the repeater fields so
quick recap on what I've done since
yesterday and then we'll get into the
code I'm streaming from home and my
computer is just kind of lagging quite a
bit here so I've been rushing to close
everything that I can that I don't need
so just let me know how the quality is
well I'll close more things as I need to
if it's if the quality is no good
alright so since yesterday I've
installed the WP graph QL a CF plugin so
this was a plugin that was in really
really early beta so it's not finished
but it is able to give me data from some
of my custom fields which is good it's
good you know some data is better than
none but the next step and what we were
working on yesterday anyway was getting
data from her Peter fields so let me
switch over to my code and to show you
what I'm what I'm trying to do to bring
that down a bit
okay so what I what I have here is that
WP graph QL ACF plugin I've forged this
and this is the fork that I'm working
with I've started a test branch and this
is gonna be where I play around and see
if I can get something to happen so far
the only thing I've done other than just
trying to figure out what's going on by
looking at all the files is I've added
that code that we had yesterday that we
tried to put in our other plugin I've
added that here and nothing really
happened
which was kind of expected right why
would the same code do anything in a
different plug-in but I thought it was
worth a shot and I've continued to look
through the code that some other people
were using and so here's let me just
tell you what I'm thinking of the next
steps to take and then you all can weigh
in as well so in this plugin
they have types PHP alright so in types
type PHP they're importing all of these
that they've created and in this folder
of you know all these so field type feel
group types are they're all separate
files and they're importing that so just
first we'll just check out you know
here's the things that they're bringing
in and then they're creating these
functions and it looks like all the
functions are doing similar things
this one's a bit more complex
and then finally if we check out one of
these types all right we can see what
they're doing in here
which looks a little bit like what we
were trying to do right so we have our
name our description right so not
exactly the same but we like I don't
know if you I'm getting a rough idea of
maybe what we could do
so let's maybe we could get a
side-by-side and that'll be easier let's
do that let's make some space here and
just compare okay so here we have two
parts to this and it looks like we also
have that here in our in our definition
what do we have up there
so looks like we have fields and type
and we also have it here it's just
flipped around all right so I guess
we'll go with fields first so fields and
then so ID so we've spelled out links
here but this is ID so our type not like
the description go why do you feel
okay yeah these are very similar so I'm
guessing that this is serving you know
the same function that this is the
difference being that this one is is
just targeting one specific custom field
and I believe that this is being applied
you know across the board to any any
custom field let's check out that type
for a second
all right that's interesting so this
this does have a lot more yeah quite a
bit more
all right so he may not need that much
may not mean that need that much but you
know maybe this gives an idea of like
what's the other stuff that we're
missing that would make this work and I
never I forgot to start my Pomodoro
timer so I'm gonna start that now
[Music]
all right so let me let me say how I had
everybody in the chat how's it going
[Music]
okay so it looks like this stream is
starting and stopping the video let me
see I'm gonna shut down my terminal so I
had some terminal windows open on my
other screen I'm shutting that down I
wanted to keep them open in case I broke
WordPress through one of the plugins
because the the only solution if he
can't get in the admin panel is then to
actually you know manually change the
files so I would need to SSH into the
droplet and change though but I could
start that up quickly enough so that
shut down and I guess I can I don't
think I have anything else open that I
could shut maybe a few things up here
yeah I do have an instance of slack open
I can shut that down looks like I have
Google Docs open
I actually I had two instances of slack
web version open so yeah definitely
don't need that and I had sheets all
right okay that's better
so got rid of some tabs open that are
notoriously heavy on resources a hub so
hopefully that'll help out a bit alright
um Christian just asks how do you go
through a plugin for WordPress I'm not
sure hmm sorry I'm not exactly sure what
you're asking so I don't know if you
could explain it just a little bit more
I might be able to answer your question
savage or red savage red I can't believe
I can read that Savage red it's it's I
wish I could edit live video I would
edit that up it says what what stack
take over technology should I use for a
modern e-commerce website it depends on
your skill level I would say the easiest
way to set up an e-commerce website that
I know of that I personally used is to
do a wordpress site and then use the
WooCommerce plugin very easy to set that
up if you've had some experience with
WordPress but I'm sure there are other
ways out there to do that I can anyway
can you do ecommerce with one others
like Magento is you can do with Magento
I've never used it so I'm not sure how
but I've just heard about it so that's
what I would say but it really does
depend on what would stack you're
already comfortable with
because that I mean that's gonna make a
big difference on how fast you can get
it up and running okay so let's go back
here and let's mess things up a bit
all right what I'll try to do let me
bring some some things over so we could
check them out I'm gonna rearrange
things just a little and alright the
screens about to get bright because for
some reason my github dark-themed no
longer works unless sure what happened
but uh it just doesn't work I don't know
maybe I don't know if github changed a
class name or something and messed it up
all right so I'm gonna make you should
get bigger there we go okay so this is
similar to what we were using that's
actually you know what it's not exactly
the same I wonder if we change some of
this if it would help yeah let's do that
let's do that okay so this is what I was
really wanted to look at is we have some
of these extra things here in in this
gist that you know I'd like to try to
maybe just add you know this see what
happens yeah I'm I think it's worth a
shot to do a little bit more but right
now what we the code that we have over
here is similar but not exactly the same
to this so I think I want to take this
and let's copy it over for now we'll
just copy it here right in the same file
because I it it may be that
some of the stuff referenced here didn't
work yesterday because it was expecting
this plug-in to be installed that I had
did not install yet the best way to do
this is probably I want to show this in
both places
here we go
so we'll have the same same file open on
both sides that'll allow us to see
everything normally you'd be able to see
enough text to do this but since I have
it displayed larger for the stream I
think I'm gonna have to do it like this
there we go
okay so I think we can change stats you
could even grab it up here and start to
change it let's try to change stats two
links in as many places as we can see
links okay and then now we can check and
see if we have any other uppercase
instances of this but I think that's it
so links okay and then in here we will
just copy and paste what we have
right because our interior fields here
are different yo and then let's just
compare down here
see this is the big difference I'm
seeing inside inside of here
yeah big difference okay so let's remove
this I think we have this still
available somewhere so okay removing it
and I'm gonna save that I'm gonna get
rid of that on that side okay so now
that I've saved this let's go with let's
make sure I haven't change anything I
didn't mean to
we're gonna commit this
all right so that should quit
unfortunately everything's really slow
but this should push up to our test
French great that's done that now we can
pull this change in right into our
plugins folder if we ssh into that that
droplet that we had so if i close it
i have to log into digital ocean again
hopefully it didn't sign me out yet I
have to go into digital ocean and just
grab the IP address and then we'll go in
and pull the changes and
with the other plugin we didn't bother
to do that we would just copy and paste
it because we had one file right copying
and pasting one file is not a big deal
you just copy everything in paste every
you know rewrite everything but with
this plug-in you know there multiple
folders and files in this particular
case we only change one piece of it but
if we were making major changes this is
definitely the better way to go because
you don't want to have to be copying and
pasting a bunch of stuff and yeah
there's much much more potential for
missing something all right
and good news is I was still signed into
digital ocean so should be able to just
go right in here
yeah and I know I sign it with root not
the best thing standard undefended so
don't be too slow in your computer
donbass renders major performance sure
improve performance would be good okay
so now let's just go back a bit
and then we should be able to go into
WWE HTML WP content and then plugins and
from plugins it'll be WP graph kilo Asya
nice alright cool
all right so it's probably covered oh no
it's you can still see the whole path so
I was able to remember the path since I
had just recently gone there no so now
that we're in here we can do a get pool
all right and now we have the changes
that we made and next step is just to
check out first of all we're gonna check
out WordPress because we'll know right
off the bat if we mess something up
badly
it just won't even work anymore page
isn't working
all right cool all right so we can
verify that this in fact was our fault
if we go let's do get check out master
and now let's try again
it's slow but alright it's working now
alright so the change that we just made
has has broken my wordpress all right
I'm not exactly sure what in here broke
it haha
probably this from getting in every line
syntax error unexpected all right
why are they expecting another you know
what I probably messed it up when I copy
and pasted it so that's my Oh fields
project label why is it like that let's
go back and look here it shouldn't be
like that right oh I copied too much
okay all right so I yeah I definitely
copy too much and try to paste it in
here so let me let me check double check
make sure I'm doing this right okay so I
just need to take out this
let's make sure
all right so this should work now let me
save it see if it [ __ ] there we go
alright it went away alright so that was
the problem copy and paste error on my
part apologies if one of you in the live
chat caught that and tried to warn me
[Music]
alright yeah maybe now I'm gonna check
the live chat just to see if anybody has
caught anything else okay Christian said
clarified an earlier question this is
well you want to add some functionality
to the WP graphical plugin how do you
review the plugin and find out how it
works
oh um basically I just I looked at the
files I read through the files I'm I'm
not gonna claim that I know how it all
works but was able to kind of get the
basic flow of what was happening I'm not
I'm not great with PHP but unfamiliar
enough with the syntax that I can kind
of tell what's going on so that's that's
what I mean by review plug-in John said
we need a screen capture that long long
frozen yawn oh it can't believe it froze
on that part oh no Christian says there
are big issues with the stream today
what else
what can I close did it start getting
worse when I when I went into this
digitalocean droplet so don't really
know what else I would I would have done
that it would have made it worse all
right well let me
actually you know what what I'm doing a
lot with yet it does slow things down so
that could also be a problem all right
so I'm gonna save this verify that this
a get commit
and then once that goes up I'll just
pull it down and then go back to the
task branch to see if it